voici donc le château de fougères sur
bièvre il est absolument magnifique
alors ses fonts baptismaux on les dames
du 11e siècle mais lui ce bâtiment en
tant que tel il est beaucoup plus tardif
on le doit à pierre de refuge pierre de
refuge c'était le conseiller spécial du
prince charles d'orléans et surtout
trésorier du fameux louis 11 alors on
dit aussi que c'est un vrai témoignage
du passage entre le médiéval et la
renaissance vous me suivez je vous guide
fougères est une pépite un château si
étonnant dans sa composition presque
hétéroclite il rassemble la toute
puissance brutale du féodalisme
affinement de la renaissance de zèle que
rien n'a semblé et pourtant est née une
addition qui enveloppent une cour
d'honneur recroquevillé posé sur un
cours d'eau et des sources à profusion
vous avez un don jours d'un côté une
grande tour de guet en eau des éléments
ouvert les mâchicoulis pour lancer des
projectiles ces petites fentes un petit
peu et parce qu'on appelle les archères
canonnière pour le tir bizarre quand
même on est au xvème siècle pour
s'aperçoit qu'il y avait quelque chose
de décalé on devrait pas trouver de
recherche canonnière au xvème siècle
mais les canonnières parce que
l'armement évolué entre temps on
maîtrise de mieux en mieux la poudre à
canon déjà au 14e siècle et pourtant ce
château encore des archères canonnière
c'est complètement archaïque et c'est ça
qui est intéressant parce que il est
dans l'aspiration du roman de chevalerie
deux ambiances meublé par le mobilier
national
on y retrouve des pièces de grande
facture reconstituant les logis d'époque
la richesse architecturale est avant
tout la signature de fougères des
frontons renaissance juché de l'archange
saint michel et des chefs-d'oeuvre de
charpenterie féodaux est plus tardif
témoin du savoir faire déjà très avancé
de l'époque le mélange est juste
savoureux
vous avez trois ans rigueur ça s'appelle
les oreilles sur cette séparation vous
avez fait un travail énorme c'est très
lourd très chargé et ça paraît
étrange que ça repose sur des piliers de
bois on a toujours l'image que le bois
n'est pas solide par rapport à la pierre
mais faut pas oublier que ça repose
dessus avant de reposer sur la tour de
pierre derrière donc c'est très
technique
fougères et ses eaux souterraines
permirent même d'y installer une
filature au 19e siècle et de donner du
travail aux villageois fougères et son
ossature imprenable qui abrita bon
nombre d'oeuvres de grands musées
parisiens pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale toute oeuvre d'ailleurs sauf
des toiles car les murs ruisselet et
soient-elles l'humidité
alors vous l'avez vu ce château ici à
fougères il incarne complètement ce
passage entre le médiéval et la
renaissance mais c'est un passage bien
vivant également il faut le faire vivre
bonjour martine valentin vous êtes
l'administratrice des lieux ici ce
magnifique lieu comment vous le faites
vivre au quotidien le faire vivre c'est
déjà le regarder le comprendre
comprendre son histoire et là il à faire
la poursuivre en quelque sorte d'où la
programmation que nous mettons en place
qui a toujours un lien avec le château
de près de loin mais avec une extension
alors les monuments nationaux sont eux
qui gèrent cet édifice ils font beaucoup
également pour que l'on puisse avoir une
pierre qui soit bien vivante oui alors
déjà nous avons 100 monuments sur le
territoire mois dans la circonscription
et territoires j'en ai quatre chats
total six châteaux dans la cathédrale de
chat il est vrai qu'il nous faut garder
une cohérence dans nos programmations la
restauration et la transmission c'est 15
mai ainsi d'ailleurs que nous allons
faire découvrir à nos téléspectateurs
alors notre fil rouge sur cette série
c'est de donner à voir aux
téléspectateurs des châteaux que l'on
connaît bien moins que chenonceaux ou
tant d'autres que nous avons dans la
région j'en passe d'autres est-ce que
c'est difficile pour des châteaux qui
sont moins médiatisés qui ont moins d'
espaces
publicitaires ou autres est-ce que c'est
difficile de vivre alors je pense qu'on
n'a peut-être pas le même nombre de
visiteurs nous avons une qualité
d'accueil de savon de qualité de lieux
nous avons belle histoire moi je les
nomme toujours ce sont des pépites des
pépites de patrimoine et je pense que le
public le sait et après avoir fait les
incontournables passe aussi dans nos
châteaux et sont rarement dessinent
ensemble martine valentin merci beaucoup
continuer à bien vous occuper de ses
pépites qui sont effectivement
formidable le château de fougères sur
bièvre passage illustré s'il en est
entre le médiéval et la renaissance une
vraie représentation demain il sera
encore question de louis 11 mais cette
fois je vous conduirai en indre et loire
au château de challenges